jerry west the laker great kind enough
to join us Jerry thank you for joining
us this morning oh thank you dance nice
to spend time with you unfortunately a
situation like this it's not a lot of
time to talk about it just up all night
thinking about a lot of personal things
that no one had a chance to share with
the two of us when when he was younger a
young aspiring 17 year old kid and every
time I turn around I just think the
devastation to not only to his family
but to the other families on board the
plane and lives cut short hoax cut short
just believe a poll of the city for a
while that's for sure why did you feel
like a surrogate father to him well he
was so young when he came here and na he
had no big that he didn't drive around
the city didn't know anything and he was
so inquisitive mm-hmm spent time with my
kids
Ryan and Johnny and johnny was a little
real little guy then and I and was
driving to control him to his first
practice he would he would eat dinner at
our house here aren't tell him who is a
places' agent at that time was wasn't
still it was a very close personal
friend of mine and it was almost like
you're you know helping a young kid get
through the minefields of just going to
college and much less a teenager who
couldn't even sign a contract cause he
is 17 years old so always wanting to go
to the gym watch him work out asked me
for anything that that I would recommend
for him which at that point in time I
did I would go work with him early on
a number of times during the first two
years here and then to watch his star
sin in Los Angeles and enormous success
he had and I saw somebody mentioned this
last night I'm not sure who it was to to
give credit to but that singular name
Koli no one ever mentioned Kobe Bryant
it was Kobe and to watch him grow and
retire 20 years with one franchise the
what a new career that was growing by
leaps and bounds he was brilliant smart
hard worker and everyone said you know
talked about the people inspired he's
pay inspired so many women that was what
to me young women he inspired them like
no other he inspired young men to chase
her dreams but to be committed and
chasing them and he had a grace about
him a few players have it a few players
have that special something
Earvin Johnson had it but he was not
Kobe Bryant Urban just played with his
smile on his face Kobe played with this
almost vindictive attitude that you're
not going to beat this team and you're
not going to beat me and frankly I think
those are the things that resonated with
because during my time when I played I
didn't like anyone I played against I
just it felt like more like a war we
played and say yesterday was a very
difficult day and this is not going to
go away from me Dan it's not going away
for a lot of people but the family so
to get his Christmas cards to see him
interact with his young girls a joy to
see him didn't go to the Laker game but
every time he went of course he would
that had him on TV and I don't go to the
Laker games and just to watch his little
girl who passed away with him
leaning up against him and hug her dad
and how to see him playing around
together and it was a tribute to a man
who had changed to come this incredible
father this iconic figure
not just in Los Angeles but all over the
world in China in Europe his ability to
speak three different languages his dad
played in Italy there is a storyline
here that this could only happen in
America and to be taking it away so
quickly he just does not seem to seem
fair at times I had a brother killed in
Korea and frankly this affected me the
same way life taken too short but my
brother was deeply religious it makes
you question faith that something like
this could happen
but I have a friend of mine we always
talk about there's a day that somebody
puts up there for you and you just never
know when it's going to be but yesterday
was a god-awful day remember the first
time you saw Kobe oh yeah you know I saw
him on film when he was high school with
a state when a state championship and
obviously it was aware of his background
because of his father and then when he
was in Los Angeles his agent wonder one
of us to work him out which we did with
some other kids and
you was by far it was like no one else
was in the gym and these people were
taken in the first round and you know
didn't think we had a chance to even get
in a running for him but his agent on
tell him again who was my friend and he
wanted him play in Los Angeles
and we had Michael Cooper to work out
with against him and Michael Cooper was
a tremendous defensive player and they
got to the point where it's almost
embarrassing to watch the
seventeen-year-old kick this old man's
fanny I called Michael at that time and
yesterday we don't need to see this
anymore this is ridiculous
as a dis guy is he's the best player in
the draft and at that time it wasn't
involved to draft 17 years old so in we
had a grander plan late Jerry Buss and I
had spent so much time together talking
about how we could re-enter ties as
franchise and more importantly I put us
in a position to be serious title
contender and our first prize was of
course Shaquille O'Neal and and didn't
think that honestly that maybe we
wouldn't have a chance but there was
other players out there that would have
been really good not him for a lot of
different reasons but and to get this
young kid through a lot of maneuvering
basically begging us to take somebody to
take our starting center who and at that
point in time you know everyone's aware
we don't want to trade with you because
of something wrong with your Center and
there wasn't anything wrong with him is
a terrific center and Vlade Divac
finally that Dec taught
accomplished and then trying to get Kobe
Bryant here and that we caught him
afterwards and I told Shaquille O'Neal
after this draft I said look I said we
got what a great it's going to be one of
the greatest players ever played this
game
I said he's young and I said he's gonna
be great and I don't know if that many
things as you kill but I think when he
got here and saw his talent and how
dominant they were together it was one
of my proudest moments and I'm sure one
of the way Jerry Buss proudest moments
to see those two guys on the court
together contain thanks to fans had 20
years of watching this enormous talent
watching him build this bridge for the
city of Los Angeles to rally behind the
Lakers and more importantly again that
singular name Kobe just it doesn't seem
right to have it hold on he's Jerry West
the Laker great Hall of Famer and he's
the one that pulled off that deal so the
Lakers could draft Kobe Bryant is there
one game that stands out to you Jerry
cuz I I want to celebrate Kobe because
there's so much to celebrate and that's
why it hurts so much is because of what
he meant to so many people but I didn't
know if there was a game or a moment
where you look back on and it makes you
smile and you know a lot of it then
happened in practice to be honest with
you okay he was you know as I say he
wouldn't you know the players would
calling Hollywood because the way he
played and he dribbled through five guys
not run employee and dunk the ball and
and you know it's all well and good to
hear the name Hollywood but I said I had
a very serious talk with him and because
he wouldn't get an opportunity to play
and he was young and wanted to play and
I said look Toby I said there's you're
playing 18 game and I said requests of
what you do you're going to be great
I said you're going to be there when the
best players ever played this game but I
said until you find their way to bridge
this gap with some of the players in
terms of not dominating the game play
within a system that causes establish
for you and it was more than once they
talked to him about it and because it
was frustrating to watch this talent
that probably need to be channeled in a
little bit different direction and when
he made that change and then I was
involved in a trade that a lot of people
weren't happy with that we traded Eddie
Jones to Miami who was an all-star
player himself and he just could not
deny Kobe Bryant he was going to take
Eddie Jones's job he's gonna do it and
it was just a matter of minutes to be
honest with you and he gave Eddie a
chance to go on and have a long
productive career in Miami and it freed
him to be COPI but there's so many
things that were personal not his POI
I mean his play was ridiculous what he
would do he did things that he was just
he was with this skill and the drive
that he had there's nothing that he was
not gonna accomplish
he was always searching for ways to get
better he was always mine was like a
steel trap in terms of that focus on his
career being the best player in the way
and he did it but I think you saw you a
little bit of you in Kobe I don't know
you do well as I say you know I was
completely different personality I was
more I was more introverted than him
and I played the game I didn't I didn't
like
as I played against to me it was more
like a war which is away Kobe approached
a game and I think that's why that just
grew that part of him grew on me and I
see the players today all smile and
giggling on the bench today team to get
beat by 20 points and it oh my gosh as a
as a player I don't think I could do
that I just don't think it's fair to the
game I don't think it's fair to the fans
you know people enjoy the incredible
personalities we have these enormous
athletes we have playing in the game
today
it was always much more serious to me
when when a fan paid to come to see a
game they paid for two things playing as
hard as you could possibly play and also
hoping that if they were rooting for the
Lakers at that point in time that they
want and had to say it's not that I
dislike players today but I wish there
was more and when I see teams laughing
in their 20 points behind oh my goodness
that really bothers me and frankly I
probably if I were running a team today
I probably would have a talk with
players because I just I don't think
that's the way should be approaches
people pay a lot of money a lot of money
to see these players play and they
played to see him because some of them
are just attract fans some of them are
you know people just admire so much
LeBron James come to mind today and a
number of others in the league but some
of them have personalities that that
people come to see and again the bond
James was one of those guys Kareem
Shaquille O'Neal and I mention those
guys
Toby Earvin Johnson and to think almost
all of the these unbelievable players
how many of them played in Los Angeles
for the city to see that kind of talent
every night you just don't see that it's
like like having a chance to go see
Whitney Houston Pavarotti
it's an event and then you get to see
him it's fleeting sometimes you yeah you
do you do get scoped oil your fans get
spoiled and their critics come out you
know all the people that were critical
of Kobe when he was you know when things
weren't going the for the team all of
the people who are now praising him
they're the same people that were
criticizing him because they were
looking to create controversy when there
was no controversy it was just a young
player and a team trying to find an
energy for themselves and I pity those
people I hated to have you on in these
circumstances but I'm glad I had you on
because you came to mind immediately in
your role in all of this and and I I
hope there's some kind of smile that you
can have at some point in this week
Jerry and and as always I appreciate
your time
well thank you Dan it's just today was
bad I mean yes it was really horrible
today really hadn't started out very
well either so it'll be a while but but
again my fault prayers go out to the
families that were affected by this and
and how devastating it was for so many
people and to lose this iconic leader of
young men and women who was in walking
on this second career again it just
doesn't seem fair
Thank You Jerry the thank you all
Famer Jerry West for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]